so you got a son
um what lessons are you going to be
teaching your son as he grows up like if
you were to pick
let's say four or five real important
lessons that you would need to cover in
the next 15 minutes what would you be
telling your son as he's growing up like
what's important
because i mean you're talking to all
these men right now too i mean
ninety-five percent
your audiences are probably um don't uh
don't drink okay drinking is is actually
the worst addiction i think
uh or or be very careful how you drink
never get drunk
a lot of people don't get that alcohol
is a drug though like i've seen people
say things like i don't hang around
people that that do drugs but
they're guzzling gallons of like liquors
right like dude that's a drug i
personally think i
i've done coke i've done booze i
personally think that booze is worse
than coke
okay so so yeah i think i've done both i
i don't know that i would agree with
that but yeah
no no i mean the effect of one is
obviously far stronger than the other
they're both [ __ ] yeah yeah
um but okay
handle your boots never get drunk never
get drunk in public
okay never get drunk period but you know
especially not in public
okay and when you realize that you're a
little bit off just get off the sauce
instantly
okay that was first uh number two
um read everything especially
non-fiction
read everything and you should have a
habit of reading you know like 50 pages
a day or something it's a great habit
and whatever whatever book comes across
you come across even if you're like sort
of like mildly interested pick it up
read it okay uh number
number three um if question anybody in
authority
that means it's not like automatically
doubt them
but ask why they think anything
if the guy knows what he's talking about
he'll be able to give you great answers
to whatever doubts you might
have okay a guy who says oh
just take my word for it i'm a phd from
harvard
he's bullshitting he's bullshitting okay
because the truth is always obvious and
simple okay
and so if somebody says x whatever it is
and you ask them if they know what
they're talking about and it's true they
will give you the explanation
instantly if they are bullshitting you
they're going to appeal to authority
appeal to their own authority or some
other authority yeah
so always question authority okay
question why somebody's saying something
okay um get in shape
that's something i deeply regret when i
was younger i did not
exercise as much as i should have and i
ate a lot of garbage a lot of
cheeseburgers
not enough broccoli i wish i
had taken better care of myself when i
was younger
and done more exercise and more physical
activity
i tend to think that i would have also
been a lot happier
i think that regular strenuous
physical exercise improves your mood
it's
very obvious to me now when i was young
you know 1922 whatever i was an idiot in
that regard
and i deeply regret that and i think a
lot of guys a lot of young guys
if they were you know working out uh you
know
daily sweating at least 30 minutes i
mean like really sweating
doesn't matter the activity running
weights whatever
but they're sweating for 30 minutes
every day
there would be a marked improvement in
every area of their lives
what do you do for self-care me
personally um
i watch my diet and i'm actually in the
process of losing some weight because i
i wasn't paying attention i started
ballooning
and uh i'm pretty happy because in the
last month or something
notice it was it you that noticed it or
was it people in the videos that said
something in the comments too
oh no i noticed it yeah you know what's
right yeah and
now i've gone down what now about uh
eight kilos in the last month eight
kilos is what about 20 pounds
yeah that's 2.2 yeah yeah uh
and um and i do a lot of walking and i
play squash i mean i
because wherever i am i always have my
office
uh between at least a kilometer away
not more than two and a half kilometers
away and i walk that
you know never take uh never drive a car
to work
and um and i play squash
once or at least once or at least once a
week
i play squash and uh squash is a great
sport
you know i mean it really keeps you know
it's hard
on the knees that's the only problem
with it and my knees are starting to go
um but um but it's a great cardio
workout
and it really it's it's a very intense
sport you know
by the way have you looked at using
bpc157 on your knees
uh what's that i have no idea what that
is i'll link it for you in the chat
afterwards but it's a peptide it's it
works really well i i pretty much fixed
my knee um
yeah a couple months ago yeah yeah
really bad left knee like i would even
be able to play
play squatch before really yeah i'll
i'll
fill you in afterwards but um okay so
that's the self-care what about
the conversation around uh money and
finances like what would you tell your
boy
i would tell him never go into debt
never
go into student debt student debt takes
on average in the united states it takes
people 21 years to pay it off
the average student debt load today is
37 000
do you think university or college is
worthwhile in north america no
not waste of time uh wasted time and
money they're not doing
anything they're not teaching you
anything um
you can have a very fulfilling life
without
a university accreditation
a fulfilling and successful life i think
that
um i think it's [ __ ]
that is being sold to young people who
don't know any better i think it's a
catastrophe
on a social level because all these
young people graduate with all these
debt
all this debt they're unable to pursue
the lives that they want to lead
they can't buy their first home until
they're in their 30s
they can't start a family when they're
young because they have this debt load
i think it's despicable what the
educational establishments have done
and uh the only people who benefit are
administrators
and bankers i personally have invested
in student bonds
it's a fantastic deal for investors but
[ __ ] for students
no it's a great deal and one of the
angles that financial institutions have
had on student loans was to
offer them other instruments like uh
lines of credit credit cards uh you know
the first car loan
rsp loans um because once they got them
on the books on the banks they know this
you know this 25 year old's probably
going to live to about whatever the
average life expectancy is 76 82 i don't
know
but they got him on the books for the
while right which means they've got him
on
the never-ending merry-go-round of debt
throwing interest payments off pretty
much for the rest of their life so i
totally agree with that
uh you know that philosophy when it
comes to education
um what about um money in general so
stay out of debt
think about like as far as investing
what about having your money have sex
with the money so that it reproduces
itself
well my thinking is that you should aim
to um
save a quarter of your gross
income gross not net uh because
here's the thing that you discover
fairly quickly once you get into the
workforce see that
uh your uh lifestyle expands to however
much income you have
and so if you don't control it yeah yeah
and so if you deliberately decide
that your your gross paycheck you're
gonna put away a quarter of it
okay just just put it away uh
you will quickly accrue a great deal of
money you will quickly
put together a very nice nest egg and
you will not feel that you are depriving
yourself of anything
okay uh that's the thing that especially
young guys they don't quite realize
because they figure
well i need to you don't need anything
you need very little
you know always be thinking that you
want to get stuff that's
like for instance you want to get a car
that's used
because a new car you drive it off a lot
and
lost a third of its value what's the
point of that okay
you you always want to be thinking like
um how can i put it any expense that you
have
you want to make sure that it's
worthwhile long term
let me give you an example a specific
example i purchased a motorcycle
last year what kind of bike i got myself
a ducati scrambler
i was looking at those the other day
great yeah
that series i'm not crazy about cafe
racers because i like to sit
upright yeah you know but uh but that's
always a sport bike guy yeah yeah i'm
i'm not crazy about sport bikes because
they scare me
you know yeah no i'm i'm too old and
bent out of shape to ride sport bikes
now
yeah but no no i had the opportunity to
get myself a ducati 999
sport bike it was modified it was
incredible incredibly fast
i took a spin around it scared the [ __ ]
out of me
life's too short you know no it's not
fun to be
riding on a bike that scares you no come
on
man if it if it can't scare me
the minute that a car or a bike doesn't
scare me
that's when i sell it that's what i'm
like okay we're done here this isn't
fast enough
my attitude is the complete opposite i
want to have a good time and
i want to relax yeah i don't want stress
no i love the adrenaline rush like
that's my thing still
oh okay now for me that that that that's
that for me that's just over i'm just
not interested in that when i was like
when i was like in my 20s sure but now
i'm just i don't want to take it easy i
just want to really
there's a picture of you here on that on
an electric motorcycle
oh yeah yeah i i uh they were test
driving it it's
actually right around my house okay and
they were like uh
letting anybody like uh test ride it it
was a lot of fun but it was like
14 000 euros yeah and you can buy it
like motorcycle for peanuts
yeah well the the thing is the scrambler
i got right
uh it was a deal it was uh one year old
it had less than a thousand miles on it
it's a triple h v twin right it's um
v twin uh 862 cc's
oh okay yeah and um nice bike
it's it's a great all-arounder okay
that's the the beauty of the of that
of that bike it's it just does
everything
very very well can you ride it year
round in amsterdam like do you get much
snow in the winter time
sure well actually there hasn't been any
snow this winter in amsterdam
okay uh and uh and no i don't have it
here i have
it in ukraine and the thing is i bought
it for
8 500 uh and it had
like i said it was a year old with less
than a thousand miles on it the new one
you know was 13 000. four thousand five
hundred dollars difference
forty fifty percent almost fifty
actually more than fifty percent
more than what i actually paid for it if
and when i get around to selling it i
put
uh another couple of thousand miles as a
matter of fact i really
hauled around on it if i were to sell it
i could get
at least eight thousand dollars from it
at least
so basically i've had a motorcycle for
about a year yeah bikes are great
transportation tools i recommend
like i don't know i i don't have it for
transportation i just do it for fooling
around right oh i used to use it for
transportation i mean for me like i'd
use it to get groceries and everything
when i was in here but i think every
young man needs to own a motorcycle i
think it's like a rite of passage like
owning a horse would have been for a boy
to a man like 300 years ago yeah
they're great but the point see it's as
an
investment would it be nicer to have
gotten the new one
yes would have been nice and nice enough
to spend
4 dollars more no and
and here's the key issue the guy who
bought it before who bought it new
and put a thousand less than a thousand
miles on it he
had to eat those forty five hundred
dollars i agree when i sell
the bike i'm gonna lose 500 bucks
big deal it cost me 500 to have a
year-round
and that's assuming that that's the low
end of the of the of the
of the sale because hottie dealers cheap
on insurance
cheap on maintenance they're great yeah
and the thing is see
the but this goes for everything
a car a house whatever okay
because a lot of times you get suckered
in to buying things
that you do not need or you don't
recognize
the depreciation of something is so high
that it's not worth getting
and that's the thing depreciation
pay attention to the depreciation of
anything any asset that you buy
a lot of times kids don't don't pay
attention because it's new it's shiny
can i get a ferrari today yes would i
get one no
because the second i drive it off a lot
i'm going to lose 120
000. that would be crazy okay
with a mclaren not with a ferrari well
i'm not so wealthy that i can afford to
throw away
you know a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars yeah i mean there are
some cars that you can make some money
on but they're pretty few and far
between and they usually offer those
vehicles
to lifelong customers of the brand like
there are ferraris that you can buy that
you can drive off the lot and they're
worth like 250
000 more than what you paid for but you
had to buy
six other ferraris from the brand before
they even offered to offer it to you
you